moments after being acquitted in a second
impeachment trial on Saturday with 57 senators
voting to convict but falling short of the
required 67 senators. Donald Trump immediately
put out a letter saying he is not going away.
We've been wondering, will Trump go away or will
he stick around in politics, at least for now?
Trump claims he is not going to go away. We will
talk later about the implications of this. But
he wrote on Saturday, we'll look at his letter.
I want to first thank my team of dedicated lawyers
and others for their tireless work upholding
justice and defending truth. Not exactly what they
did, but OK, Trump says, my deepest thanks as well
to all of the United States senators and members
of Congress who stood proudly for the Constitution
we all revere and for the sacred legal principles
at the heart of our country. Well, they didn't
many of them wrongly said you can't try and or
convict a former president. That is not actually
the reality. Constitutionally, Trump goes on
to say, our cherished constitutional republic
was founded on the impartial rule of law, the
indispensable safeguard for our liberties and our
rights and our freedoms. It is a sad commentary
on our times that one political party in America
is given a free pass to denigrate the rule of law,
defame law enforcement, cheer mobs, excuse rioters
and transform justice into a tool of political
vengeance and persecute blacklist, cancel and
suppress all people with viewpoints with whom,
that which, with whom or which they disagree.
That sounds like what the rioters did. Trump
saying that to criticize, I guess, Democrats,
he goes on and says, I always have and always
will be a champion for the unwavering rule of law,
the heroes of law enforcement and the right of
Americans to peacefully and honorably debate the
issues of the day without malice and without
hate. This has been yet another phase of the
greatest witch hunt in the history of our
country. No president has ever gone through
anything like it. Well, no president has ever
done the things Trump did. And it continues
because our opponents cannot forget the almost
75 million people, the highest number ever for
a sitting president who voted for us just a few
short months ago. No one's forgetting them. We
remember them and were horrified by them. Nobody's
forgotten them. I also want to convey my gratitude
to the millions of decent, hardworking, law
abiding God and country loving citizens who
have bravely supported these important principles
in these very difficult and challenging times.
Our history, historic, patriotic and
beautiful movement to make America great again
has only just begun a key moment in the
months ahead. I have much to share with you,
and I look forward to continuing our incredible
journey together to achieve American greatness for
all of our people. There has never been anything
like it. We have so much work ahead of us and soon
we will emerge with a vision for a bright, radiant
and limitless American future. Together, there is
nothing we cannot accomplish, Trump saying. We
remain one people, one family and one glorious
nation under God. And it's our responsibility
to preserve this magnificent inheritance for our
children and for many generations, for generations
of Americans to come. May God bless all of you
and may God forever bless the United States. I
know that's not true. He did say United States.
It was in writing so the slur didn't apply. So
most of what Trump says is completely backwards,
but that's not surprising. I wasn't expecting
Donald Trump to suddenly tell the truth.
But the matter of practical importance here is
that of if and how Trump will remain in politics
and remain a force in the Republican Party, not
forever, but at least for the next few years.
We know based on a poll from 10 days
ago, 64 percent of Republican voters
said it said they would follow Trump to
another party, 64. Two thirds almost of
the Republican Party is willing to leave if
Trump says, here's my new party, come with me.
And with Trump putting out a statement like this,
it doesn't seem as though Trump is planning to go
quietly. Now, the questions that remain include
will Trump's involvement in Republican politics
help Republicans or hurt them in twenty twenty
one in the. Turrill races that there are,
will Trump's involvement in the Republican Party
help or hurt them in twenty, twenty two when
they want presumably to take back control of the
House of Representatives, take back control of the
Senate? Will Trump end up criminally charged in
Georgia, where he's under criminal investigation
in New York, in other states? And will that
interfere with Donald Trump's political plans? And
will the Republican Party, which for now is still
officially speaking, mostly behind Donald Trump,
will they sour with Trump and say enough is
enough at some point? These are the questions
we don't yet know the answers, but judging from
what Donald Trump is saying, he's going to try
something in the next few months in terms of an
involvement. And we will see how the Republican
Party reacts. Curious to know your thoughts. We'll
have more coverage of this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page, which you can find at The
David Pakman Show. Find me on Instagram at David
Pakman. And we will be back right after this.
I will argue that the extremist wing of the
Republican Party has become too big to fail. The
radicals are too numerous to simply go away. And
we'll talk about that after the break. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.